في السودان مجلس البيجا يعلن الاول من
ابريل موعدا لاغلاق الشرق ليوم واحد رفضا
للاتفاق السياسي
روسيا تبدا تدريبات تشمل انظمه صواريخ
يارس النوويه الباليسيه العابره للقارات
سجال امريكي اسرائيلي بشان تعديلات القضاء
وجلسه الحوار بين المعارضه والائتلاف
الحاكم تتواصل اليوم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء من
العربيه يقدموها لكم ابراهيم بدر اعلن
مجلس البجا جناح ترك الاول من ابريل موعدا
للاغلاق الشامل لشرق السودان رفضا للاتفاق
السياسي حسب بيان اكد فيه مجلس البجاء انه
يقف ضد اي عمليه سياسيه او جدول زمني
لتكوين حكومه يرفضها 90% من الشعب
السوداني على حد قوله وطلب بيان مجلس
البيجا القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع
بالوقوف على مسافه واحده من الجميع
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان القوات
الاستراتيجيه الصاروخيه روسيه بدات
تدريبات مقرره تشمل انظمه صواريخ النوويه
الباليسيه العابره للقارات واضافت في بيان
عبر تطبيق تيليجرام للمراسلات ان اكثر من
3000 فرد عسكري وحوالي 300 قطعه اعتاد في
المجمل شاركت في التدريبات
اعلن قائد القوات الجويه الامريكيه
فرانكيندال عن فشل اختبار الاسلحه فرضيه
الذي اجرته القوات الامريكيه كندال اوضح
ايضا ان فشل اختبار الاسلحه فرط الصوتيه
يعود لعدم تمكنها من تحقيق النتائج
المرجوه
كما اعلن قائد القوات الجويه الامريكيه عن
زياده انتاج مقاتلات اف 35 واف 15 دون ان
يحدد مستوى الانتاج الجديد وفي وقت سابق
قالت المتحدثه باسم نهايه الاركان
المشتركه للقوات المسلحه الامريكيه ساره
جوينز او جوينر قالت ان البنتاجون يتوقع
بيع ثلاث وثمانين مقاتله من طراز اف 15 او
f 35
و24 مقاتله من طراز اف 15 اكس وغواصه
نوويه واحده في غضون العام المقبل
كشف اعضاء من وحده هجوم روسيه تم تشكيلها
مؤخرا ان قادتهم نشروا قوات خاصه لمنعهم
من التراجع وهددوهم بالقتل بعد ان تكبدوا
خسائر فادحه في شرق اوكرانيا وفقا لصحيفه
يريدون اعدامنا بهذه العباره اشتكى جنود
الروس على ساحات القتال في اوكرانيا من
تكتيك وصفوه بالوحشي يتبعه قادتهم معهم
كاستراتيجيه على ارض المعركه تكتيك يعتمد
بالاساس على وحده هجوم عسكريه روسيه تسمى
بقوات الجدار او القوات المناهضه للانسحاب
هي وحدات عسكريه تتمركز خلف قوات الخطوط
الاماميه عملها الاساسي الحفاظ على انضباط
الجنود وردعهم ومنعهم من التراجع او
الانسحاب وحتى الفرار والقبض على الجواسيس
بحسب مقطع فيديو نشرته صحيفه جارديان
البريطانيه يظهر مجموعه جنود من وحده
العاصفه التابعه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
التي انشات في يناير للمشاركه في هجوم
موسكو الشتوي الطاحن في شرق اوكرانيا شكلت
تلك الوحده خصيصا لاختراق اكثر قطاعات
الدفاع تعقيدا في القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه بعد خسائرهم الفادحه في تلك
المعركه قدم اولئك الجنود شهادات تؤكد
تعرضهم للتهديد بالقتل على يد قادتهم
واجبارهم على اعطاء اموال لقادتهم ومن
يرفض يعاقب بارساله الى الخطوط الاماميه
للقتال
لقد وضعوا قوات جدار خلفنا ولم يسمحوا لنا
بمغادره موقعنا هددوا بتدميرنا واحدا تلو
الاخر وكوحدا يريدون اعدامنا كشهود على
قياده اجراميه مهمله تماما وفقا للجارديان
فان الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا تسببت في
الكثير من الازمات للجيش الروسي ليس على
مستوى ساحات المعركه فحسب بل داخل صفوفه
وهو ما فسرته سابقا وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه بانه دليل على تدني الجوده
وانخفاض الروح المعنويه وعدم انضباط
القوات الروسيه
بعد ان تم العفو عن اكثر من خمسه الاف
مجرم سابق في روسيا بعد انهاء عقودهم
للقتال في صفوف مجموعه ايفاجنر العسكريه
الخاصه باوكرانيا تبدا الشركه بحمله
اعلاميه لاستقطاب مقاتلين جدد الى صفوفها
التفاصيل طعمه من موسكو
على الاطراف الشمال شرقيه للعاصمه الروسيه
موسكو والذي يبث على شاشه مبنى في منطقه
سفرنيز يحمل نداء للانضمام الى صفوف
المتطوعين في بعضنا
هذا الاعلان للشركه والذي هو ليس بالاول
في روسيا ياتي الان وفقا للخبراء بعد ان
توقفت الشركه العسكريه عن تجنيد السجناء
الروس للمشاركه في العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا
مؤسس فاغوشن اكد على ان الشركه قامت
بافتتاح مراكز لتجنيد المتطوعين في 42
مدينه روسيه حيث تعرض رواتب مغريه مقابل
الذهاب الى ارض المعركه كانت طعم العربيه
موسكو
اعلنت الخرجه الامريكيه انا مسؤولا
امريكيا الاسبوع الماضي بعد نحو شهرين على
الغاء واشنطن زياره مقرره لوزير الخارجيه
على خلفيه رصد منطاد صيني وزاره رئيس
الدائره الصينيه في الخارجيه الامريكيه
ريكو بوتلز العاصمه بكين وشنغها اعلنه
متحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه في تصريح
الصحفيين وقربتيل من اهميه الزياره ولم
يشاء الكشف عن المواضيع التي تم بحثها او
نتائج التي خلصت اليها المحادثه
من المنتظر ان يتواصل اليوم في اسرائيل
الحوار بين ممثلين عن الائتلاف الحاكم
واحزاب المعارضه لحل ازمه التعديلات
القضائيه وكان مكتب الرئيس الاسرائيلي
اسحاق قال ان جلسه امس جرت في اجواء جيده
وحسب الصحافه الاسرائيليه فقد منع المدعي
العام بنمين نتنياهو من تمثيل حزب اليكود
في الحوار التشريعي
وفي اول رد له على الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن الذي حذر من ان اسرائيل لا يمكنها
مواصله مسار المواجهه القضائيه قال الرئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهون
اسرائيل دوله مستقله تتخذ قراراتها دون اي
ضغوط خارجيه وكان بايدن اعرب عن امله في
ان يتراجع ان نتنياهو عن قانون التعديلات
القضائيه كما اكد الرئيس الامريكي انه لا
توجد دعوه
لزياره البيت الابيض على المدى القريب
قالت ان نقابات الفرنسيه ان اكثر من
مليونين متظاهر شاركوا في احتجاجات امس في
عموم البلاد على قانون رفع سن التقاعد
وقررت النقابات تنظيم يوم تحرك شعبي جديد
الخميس السادس من ابريل في المقابل قالت
الشرطه الفرنسيه ان عدد المتظاهرين بلغه
نحو 740 الف في انحاء البلاد كافه بينهم
93 في باريس وحدها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مظاهر العنف المتزايده خلال الاحتجاجات في
فرنسا باتت تدعو للقلق وهو مدفع الحكومه
الفرنسيه الى دقه ناقوس الخطر وتوعد
المشاغبين بعقوبات قاسيه حيث اتهم وزير
الداخليه الفرنسيه جيرالدا
دغمنا مجموعات من المحتجين بالتورطي في
اعمال عنف ضخمه سابقا منها تدمير ممتلكات
وابتزاز قوات النظام مشيرا الى انه سيتقدم
بحل للاحتجاجات في اجتماع مجلس الوزراء
المقبل
ارى العنف الشديده لبعض المجموعات الصغيره
كما ترونه انتم والتي اظهرت اجهزه
المخابرات انها مسجله منذ سنوات عديده
كمسؤوله عن اعمال عنف كبيره ومسؤوله عن
عمليات ابتزاز قويه ضد قوات النظام وتدمير
الممتلكات ووقوع مئات الجرحى من رجال
الشرطه نتيجه لتدميرهم لذلك قررت الشروع
في حل للاحتجاجات والذي سا في جلسه اجتماع
مجلس الوزراء المقبل
في تصعيد جديد نزول الاف من عناصر الشرطه
الفرنسيه الى الشوارع لكبح الاحتجاجات
تصعدون الحقه اوليفيي بالقول ان الحكومه
حصن ضد العنف غير المصبوق
المتظاهرون يوصلون اضرابهم ليصل الى قطع
الطرقات وازمه الوقود تشير المعلومات الى
نفاذ الوقود بنسبه 15% من محطات الوقود في
فرنسا اخر استطلاعات الراي تؤكد تراجع
شعبيه
في شهر واحد
ففي الوقت الذي يعتبر 30% ماكرون رئيسا
جيدا ينظر اليه 70% بسلبيه
النقابات لا تنوي التراجع وتحذر من خروج
الاحتجاجات عن السيطره وبينما تريد
النقابات مراسلات الا ان ادارته غير
متحمسه للوساطه
موقف يضع حكومه ماكرون في حرج اذا تراجعت
ستبدو ضعيفه وان سر ستؤجج النار المشتعله
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعنا فيها بعض الفاصل
رئيس الامريكي يحذر من ان الازمه المصرفيه
لم تنتهي بعد وسط تراجع الثقه المستثمرين
اهلا بكم من جديد عربه وزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه عن ادانه ورفضي المملكه للاقتحام
السافر الذي نفذه مستوطنون اسرائيليون
لباحات المسجد الاقصى وسط حمايه القوات
الاسرائيليه واكدت الخارجيه السعوديه في
بيانا ان هذه الممارسات تقوض جهود السلام
وتتعارضوا مع المبادئ والاعراف الدوليه في
احترام المقدسات الدينيه
فرضت الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا عقوبات
على مسؤولين عن تجاره الكيتاجون غير
القانونيه في سوريا وذكر بيان للخزانه
الامريكيه ان العقوبات تشمل سته اشخاص من
بينهم اثنان من عائله رئيس النظام السوري
بشار الاسد بينما طالت العقوبات
البريطانيه احد عشر كيان مرتبطا بالنظام
السوري وقالت الخزانه الامريكيه ان بعض
مهاربين مخدرات اللبنانيين عبر سوريا على
صله بحزب الله بدورها شددت وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه على ان واشنطن ستواصل مع
الحلفاء مواجهه تجاره المخدرات في المنطقه
مشيره الى ان امريكا ستعاقب من يدعم الحرب
الشرسه على السوريين
اعلن الرئيس انه فعل كل ما بؤسه لمعالجه
الازمه المصرفيه محذرا من انها لن تنتهي
بعد جاء ذلك في وقت تراجعت ثقه المستثمرين
في قطاع المصرفي اثر انهيار بنوك سيليكون
فالي وسجنشر وسيلفر جي
في افغانستان اعتقلت حركه طالبان ناشيطان
افغانيا في مجال تعليم الفتيات دون ذكر
سبب احتجازه مطيع الله وسعيناضل من اجل حق
الفتيات في الدراسه منذ ان منع الطلبان
تعليمهن عام 2021
لم تكتفي طالبان بمنع الفتيات من دخول
الفصول الدراسيه فحسب بل القى الطالبان
القبضه على الناشط الافغنيا بارز في مجال
تعليم الفتيات الافغانيات
الامم المتحده طالبت طالبان بتوضيح سبب
احتجاز مطيع والذي ياتي اعتقاله وسط القبض
على عدد من النشاطات الذين كانوا يناضلون
من اجل تعليم المراه ويسال بالغ من العمر
30 عاما يسافر الى مناطق نائيه من
افغانستان لتحسين فرص حصول جميع الاطفال
على التعليم رغم تلقيه تهديدات كثيره
يدافع ويس الذي ينحدر من اقليم قندهار
جنوبي افغانستان منذ سنوات عن تعليم
الفتيات لا سيما في المناطق الريفيه
المحافظه
وانشا منظمه مسار القلم قائلا ان الخدمات
التعليميه لا تصل لكثير من الفتيات اللائي
يعيشن في الريف
تاكلت حقوق المراه تدريجيا منذ عوده
طالبان الى السلطه عام 2021 بعد الانسحاب
الامريكي من اغلاق المدارس والجامعات حتى
يتم خلقه بيئه مناسبه على حد قولهم الى
اعاقه اعمالهن عن طريق منعهن من العمل في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه المحليه والدوليه
باستثناء القطاع الصحي هذا ويتعرضنا
الافغانيات لقيود شديده بطرق اخرى ايضا
حيث اصدر الطالبان مرسوما يقضي بضروره
تغطيه النساء بطريقه تكشف عن اعينهم فقط
ويجب ان يرافقهن قريبا ذكر اذا كنا يسافرن
اكثر من 72 كيلومترا كما تم منع النساء من
دخول الحدائق وصلت الرياضيه رشا خياط
العربيه
من المدينه المنوره الى العالم هو اخر
مشاريع التطويريه التي شهدتها المنطقه
المركزيه بالمسجد النبوي والذي يقع على
مسافه 20 الف متر مربع ويضم ثمانيه عشر
مطبخا من مختلف البلدان الاسلاميه لتتناسب
مع كافه اذواق الزائرين طوال شهر رمضان
التفاصيل رفقه الزميل سلطان السلمى
[موسيقى]
المدينه المنوره تعتبر ثاني اهم مدينه
للعالم الاسلامي حيث تضم المسجد النبوي
وقبر النبي محمد حيث يفيد اليها سنويا
اكثر من ثمانيه ملايين مسلم من شتى بقاع
الارض الان المنطقه صارت جدا جدا مكتظه
بالحجاج والمعتمرين التوجيه صار على جهه
واحده تركيز الحجاج كلهم صار على جهه
واحده المساحات صارت اكبر تعدد الثقافات
فرصه تجاره جدا جدا كويسه في المنطقه هذه
من المدينه المنوره الى العالم هو عنوان
مشروع المنطقه المركزيه
المجاور للمسجد النبوي الذي يقع على مساحه
عشرين الف متر مربع ويضم ثمانيه عشر مطبخا
من مختلف البلدان الاسلاميه
لتتناسب مع كافه اذواق الزائرين طوال شهر
رمضان اضافه الى مركز استعلامات
ومحله لبيع التذكارات ومسارات مهيئه الى
ساحات المسجد الحقيقه المكان رائع جدا هذه
الاختلاف
التعدد الدول بالاكلات والمطاعم الرقابه
الجميله الرائعه جدا يعني واحد من ياكل
مامن انه مطمئنه اني اكل هنا بهذا الاماكن
هي جوار وطمانينه هي مدينه الرسول عليه
الصلاه والسلام فاني لمست هاي الطمانينه
اللي احنا افتقدناها لسنوات طويله بالعراق
لكن اذا احب اشتري اشياء تذكاريه اشياء
كثيره يعني اشياء السجادات الاسلاميه
[موسيقى]
السلاسل الاسلاميه انا احب اكون اولادي
يتذكرون العمره اللي انا سويتها باشياء
جميله بيها طابع تراثي سعودي اسهمت
المشروعات الحديثه التي انجزت في المنطقه
المركزيه بالمدينه المنوره في تحسين
المشهد الحضري ورفع مستوى جوده الحياه في
الطرق والشوارع المحيطه
وتهيئتها بشكل اكبر للمشاه وقاصدي المسجد
النبوي الشريف من المدينه المنوره سلطان
السلمي العربيه
في نهايه نشرح هذا التذكير بابرزه
عناوينها
في السودان مجلس البدا يعلن الاول من ابن
الموعد لاغلاق الشرق ليوم واحد رفضا
للاتفاق السياسي
روسيا تبدا تدريبات تشمل انظمه صواريخ
يارس النوويه البالسيه العابره للقارات
وسجال امريكي اسرائيلي بشان تعديلات
القضاء وجلسه الحوار بين المعارضه
والائتلاف الحاكم تتواصل اليوم
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]